everything in your life changes when you
learn to tie your selfworth to your
effort instead of the results most
people tie their self worth to the
results to winning you only feel good
about yourself when you win if that's
how you think then you're screwed
because that person only takes on
projects that you know you have a pretty
high chance of winning at and therefore
you play small for Life the key is to
tie your self worth to the effort so
let's use me as an example look at this
video right here this video 2 minutes
before getting on to making this video
I'm nervous I'm scared I don't want to
do it I'm trying to find a reason why I
don't have to do this video now why I've
done 6,000 of these videos the answer is
because I don't want to make it the same
way that I've done the past 6,000 I want
to push harder I want to push and do
something new if I was just doing what
I've already done then it'd be easy want
a sore get a mentor hey it's Nina
Carmichael and we made these videos it's
probably because you're the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you need
that Porche by surround yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Evan carmichel
when you learn how to do this Everything
Changes
[Music]
enjoy and so the answer isn't have a big
goal and then find a reason why you
can't do it the answer isn't dream big
and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is to push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
going to do it anyway the answer for me
is I'm going to make another video I'm
going to try and push myself harder and
I think that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm I'm just failing it's another
failure another failure another
failure but the more you fail the more
you're eventually going to win I'm going
to get massive
results because you tie yourself Worth
to your ability to get up and try again
and try again and try again hand and pat
yourself on the back for the effort
you're putting in not just when you're
winning so how do you do it I'm going to
give you a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is what
I call the pillow test this is my actual
pillow that when I'm in Toronto I sleep
on every single night and the pillow
test is make yourself proud before you
hit your head on the pillow right before
you go to sleep tonight before your head
hits your pillow you ask yourself am I
proud of my effort today not how much
did I win not not did I get the results
I was looking for not that I get my
million views or close that big sale are
you proud of your effort are you proud
of your effort can you put your head on
your pillow tonight and say man I am
proud of the effort that I put in that's
a test that's the test for tonight
that's your test for tomorrow night and
the night after that and the night after
that and the night after that and the
more that you get a yes to say yeah heck
yeah heck yeah I'm proud of my effort
you do that you you watch your business
explode step number two is expect to
suck at the start anytime you're trying
something new expect to suck don't
expect to just try something new and
it's amazing this is where a lot of
people fall down you've had some success
you're at a certain level you're going
to try something new before you go up
you're probably going to go down that's
part of the experimentation process it
doesn't mean you suck as a human it just
means that you don't have the skill sets
the talents yet you're trying something
new I haven't brought props in on my
videos before that was a new test I
expect it to suck maybe on a on an off
chance it works amazing I learned from
it but when you're trying something it's
brand new you don't have the confidence
in it yet you're still figuring out the
path expect to suck when you put so much
of your worth into expecting to be great
the first time out here's what happens
you try one thing you record one video
you watch it back say man that sucked
and then you never make a video again
meanwhile if you just kept doing it you
would eventually be awesome you
eventually crush it go back and watch my
first videos go back go back to my main
Channel go back to the beginning see
where I started I've kept them all up so
you can see the journey the progress of
how much I sucked at the very beginning
it took me 350 videos until I wasn't
embarrassed by my content I was I was so
embarrassed I couldn't watch it back 350
videos but I kept going the problem is
people are quitting on things too soon
you quit on something too soon because
you're not getting immediate results
expect to suck it doesn't mean that you
suck as a human it just means you don't
have the skills yet and how do you get
the skills by practicing and number
three is ask yourself what would the
most bold version of you do I got this
question was talking to my video guy
Danny who came to me with a really
important personal problem in his life
at the time and I said what would the
most bold version of you do it just came
out man I love that and anytime he
doesn't know what to do he asked himself
that question what would the most bold
version of me do it's a great question
because it allows you to push through a
lot of your fears a lot of your
insecurities to force yourself to be
bold and you want to be bold you're
meant to be bold you're meant to create
amazing wonderful things you want that
big vision of yours to come true you are
bold you are courageous but we don't
live in that land very often and so if
you ask that question what would the
most bold version of you do today what
it does is wash away a lot of those
fears and insecurities and gives you the
answer that you're actually looking for
rule number two be your biggest critic
and fan what do you say when you see
yourself in the mirror when it's just
you when you're all alone it's just you
you see yourself in the mirror what do
you say do you say great things or do
you beat yourself up most people they
might act confident and seem like they
have it all put together but secretly
they're fighting their own battles and
at home in private the comfort of their
own home they're their own worst enemies
the secret is to be your own biggest
critic as well as your biggest fan the
push you give yourself has to be from a
place of love and potential not lack and
despair so I recently posted on
Instagram a little cartoon of me passing
by a mirror and you see my reflection in
the mirror and the caption says I love
you and then I challenge people to say
hey what do you what do you say to
yourself when you look in the mirror and
giving them an 18-day challenge to say
every time you see a reflection of
yourself to say something positive
whether it's I love you or give yourself
a compliment something positive because
I think most people live in the land of
negativity all we see is all the
negative things that we're doing and all
the things that didn't work out and
things that could have been better and
that can actually be very healthy I
think you need to be your own biggest
critic I think you need to have higher
standards for yourself than what you're
currently doing but it only works being
your own biggest critic only works when
it's based off a foundation of
love when it's based off a foundation of
I an amazing human being and I love
myself and I suck at all of these skills
the problem that most people have is you
see that you suck at a skill that you
didn't get the result that you're not
good on camera the first time you go out
you didn't get the result you didn't
land the sale you didn't make the deal
you didn't get the date you know
whatever it is you didn't get the result
and then you think that you suck as a
human because you don't have the skills
it's the opposite you you're amazing as
a human it has to be from a foundation
of love that you love yourself and that
you suck at the skills and then you can
beat yourself up over how do I get
better how do I improve how do I acquire
the skills how do I move forward towards
my goals most people are their own
bigest critic but they're not their
biggest fan and I'm going to give you a
three-step process on how to change it
step number one is take the 18-day flexx
challenge so if you want to go to
ever.com flex the x.pdf you can get the
same calendar that I use it's not here
it's somewhere it's in my bedroom so
where I usually keep it and every day
for the next 18 days you challenge
yourself that whenever I see myself
reflective surface a mirror the cell
phone whatever I'm going to say
something positive to myself in fact
just make that your cell phone
background and that when you see your
your login screen or your home screen on
your cell phone background on your
desktop it says something positive about
you and it's a reminder I have to say
something positive about myself just for
18 days try it flexx challenge why 18
days because it takes at least 18 days
to build a habit science says that it
takes 18 to 254 days to build a habit
it's why I have my 254 series cuz I'm
there with you every step of the way and
the average is actually 66 days of
consecutive action it means no time off
no days off to build a habit but the
minimum is 18 days so just try it for 18
days just try what's going to happen in
18 days the worst is you're saying
something you don't believe about
yourself for 18 you can handle it you'll
be okay the best case scenario is you
actually start to love yourself a little
bit more and the things that you can do
when you believe in yourself and you
love yourself are tremendous so step
number one is take the 18-day flex DX I
love you challenge step number two is
being your own biggest critic as well as
your biggest fan you need to do both and
so so ask yourself the criticism that
I'm giv myself when I look at my videos
when I look at my content when I look at
how I'm handling my team when when you
look at all the things that you're
supposed to be doing that you are doing
on a daily basis and you beat yourself
up identify the parts that are just a
skill set that you rock that you're
amazing that you're the best but you
just don't have the skill set yet and
how do you fix it how do you acquire the
skill set through more practice through
more research through model and success
that you can get there so split it up
having that cognitive ability to say I'm
being hard on myself but really it's
just a skill set that I'm lacking and
I'm
awesome makes a big difference so start
doing it today and step number three is
kick yourself forward not down this
often comes when you're comparing
yourself to others you're comparing
yourself to somebody else who's in your
field who's ahead of you or somebody who
you went to high school with or
university with and and they have a
bigger job than you or making more money
and have more kids or whatever it is
that you're jealous of you kick yourself
down you say I suck well they they're
off doing this and they acquired this by
the time that they were your age and and
you suck you're not doing anything
you're nowhere close right that's
kicking yourself down that's not helpful
what you need to do is kick yourself
forward what you need to do is look at
that and say that's what's possible
that's the potential that's what that's
what you can be capable of doing but
here's the thing I think you actually
need the kick I think the comparison is
good I think it's healthy I think the
problem with the comparison is you're
only looking at it from the negative
because you actually don't love yourself
yet you have to build that up right do
the 18-day flex X challenge it's based
out of love to say that this is what's
possible cuz without the kick without
the comparison you stay where you are
the key though is you're kicking
yourself forward to say that's what's
possible that's what I want to create
somebody else has done it I can do it
too I've got Michael Jordan level Talent
I'm going to go off and crush it instead
of kicking yourself down and saying that
you suck and you're never going to get
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three ask for help not
asking for help is selfish you might
think that trying to do everything
yourself is selfless that it's wrong to
ask for help and Noble to do everything
yourself but you love helping people you
love helping others remember that Joy
you feel when you help somebody and
brought a smile to their face knowing
you made their weak by you not asking
for help you're cheating people of that
opportunity to bring a smile to their
face stop being selfish and start asking
for help I came up with this idea when I
was at a video game Cafe so here's what
happened I was I was on a call with one
of my big customers at the time and I
was in Los Angeles and we're doing a a
Google live streaming to my YouTube
channel lots of people watching YouTube
live I'm interviewing him and then the
internet goes down like what happened
the power went out across all of Los
Angeles the power goes out and it and
it's down I got nothing I the stream is
still live but I'm not there anymore I
left my client live on the stream and
he's he's not sure what happens he just
sees my camera go down and then he keeps
going by himself for another 15 20
minutes waiting for me to come back and
he's he's embarrassed and it's awkward
and he doesn't know what he's doing cuz
the host who has the audience there is
now gone and then eventually he just
leaves because said well I don't know
where Evan is but thank you guys for
watching watching and it put him in a
really difficult situation I felt
terrible I went back to watching the
live stream after like oh my God I can't
believe that happened now it's out of my
control you know internet goes down in
Los Angeles what I what am I supposed to
do there's no power anywhere so as soon
as the power gets back up I message my
my client and say hey man I'm really
sorry about that let's reschedule it
let's do it again when I'm back home in
Toronto where I know I have stable
internet and and I want to do it again
for free no extra cost uh even though we
had almost finished the live stream
together we're going to do a whole other
one for free just because I want you to
I want to make this right for you great
so we come back to Toronto it's like the
a week or two later and my internet is
pretty Rock Solid in my home office I've
never had an internet issue really
happened while I was doing a live stream
but I wanted to make extra sure extra
sure that this time nothing happened
because if something happened the second
time like just it would not be a good
thing so I asked my friend friend J rise
and said J rise I need I need a place
that has Rock Solid internet that I'm
going to do this live stream and nothing
can go wrong and he said I got a place
there an internet cafe that that I go to
I'll introduce you to the owner I know
him and and you can do it there like
thank you so much so we go there I'm
there an hour early I'm setting up I'm
talking to the owner I'm testing the
gear my microphone the headset all of it
the camera testing all of it just to
make sure that everything is working
smoothly I'm nervous because the last
time with it failed on us my client
comes on we go live for a half an hour
an hour I don't remember and and it was
smooth perfect no issues crisp amazing
internet blazing fast speeds great time
with the audience and we delivered an
awesome
product sigh of relief right I'm so
pumped I go talk to the owner say dude
thank you man it was perfect no
complaints no problems thank you so much
how much do I owe
you and he said well you were on on the
computer for about an hour and a half
and jrj was on the computer for about an
hour and a half but I I'll just bundle
it together so I fig what he told me it
was like five bucks or seven bucks or 10
bucks or something like are you kidding
me I would have paid $1,000 I would have
paid a lot of money just to make sure
that this went smoothly because it's the
it's the relationship with my client at
the time right I said okay well let me
great here's here's the $7 that you
wanted awesome let me buy let me buy
some some stuff from behind the counter
though let me buy some snacks for my
friend Jr JZ was hungry he needed to eat
so like here here's 20 bucks 25 bucks
let me just buy out a whole bunch of
your snacks and give it to him he's like
no no no you don't have to do that man
don't worry about it like no I want to
do it let me buy out the snack no no no
don't worry about
it the owner thought that he was doing a
good thing the owner thought that he was
being selfless that hey don't worry
about you don't have to do it that just
just paying for the internet was enough
for him but he was actually being
selfish
in that moment he was being selfish
because he cheated me of the opportunity
of one saying thank you I wanted to pay
more I want to pay more you're cheating
me of the opportunity to do it and
you're cheating me of the opportunity to
help my friend J rise and give him some
food cuz he was hungry so we had to go
somewhere else you need to be willing to
bring other people in you need to be
willing to ask for help yes you don't
want to waste your time yes you want to
be respectful yes but people love
helping others we are built to serve you
want to help other people that joy that
you feel when you help somebody out
allow it to come into other people's
hearts too and it only comes when you
open up and you ask for help and you say
hey I would I'm really struggling with
this thing right now and and I would I
could really use some help and people
may not be willing to do it may not have
the time to do it don't be too pushy and
don't be too overwhelming
but don't be selfish at the same time
too so now how do you do it I'm going to
give you a three-step process on how to
ask for help and stop being selfish step
number one is what are you struggling
with right now what are you struggling
with right now where do you need help in
your business listen entrepreneurship is
rough right you're wearing all the hats
what do you need the most help with now
whether it's strategy whether it's a new
skill set you need to learn whether it's
just basic whether it's just taking off
some of the the operational stuff that
you have to do in your business right
the day-to-day the the grind that just
overwhelmed with Project work what do
you need help with number two who is an
expert at that thing who do you know who
have you helped before who's in your
circle who is an expert at that thing
who by them spending a little bit of
time with you could make a really big
impact on your business make that list
and step number three is reach out to
them with love appreciation and zero
expectations explain the story explain
how much this would mean to you explain
why you're struggling and how you want
to use use this thing to get to the next
level in your business in your career in
your mission in your vision and then how
they could be an important part of it
with love but zero expectations if they
say they're busy don't be hurt by it if
they say sorry I can't help that's okay
but reach out don't take the yes away
from them the problem when you don't
reach out is you're saying no for them
when you don't reach out you're saying
no for them and a lot of people would
want to say yes to you rule number four
become a shark you haven't become a
shark yet because you haven't decided
that your mission is important enough
now being a shark doesn't mean that you
have to become aggressive violent and
angry it means that you're pushing to be
the best in your industry a true leader
someone who makes a difference and it
starts with your mission raise the level
of how important your mission feels to
you and your entire life changes so I
look at my Mission as an example I want
to solve the world's biggest problem
it's never going to happen I'm trying to
solve the biggest problem I think in the
world which is that lack of belief in
yourself the untp potential is what I
wake up every day trying to do and the
more that I put myself in a position of
this thing matters like what I do really
really really matters the more I can put
myself in that mind frame the bigger my
thinking becomes the Bolder I get as a
human and as an entrepreneur and I look
at the path that I've taken over the
past X number of years I look at being
able to collaborate with someone like
Eric Thomas when he gave a shout out in
his video that would have been something
I wouldn't have thought of when I first
started on YouTube I look at the
relations I built with people like Tony
Robbins and Gary vaynerchuk and Grant
Cardone and the people that we profile
Tony Robbins I took the people on my
team to go see him at Unleash the Power
Within I brought five I think of my
people down and we're sitting up in the
cheap seats and then a year later a year
later he invited me as his personal
guest to sit right down in the front row
chairman invited seating and I'm going
back I leave tomorrow I don't know when
this video goes up but I leave tomorrow
for Dallas to do it
again it's wild right like it doesn't
feel like that stuff is
possible it comes from Shifting the
value of your your mission I deserve it
because what I'm doing is solving a real
problem and we often feel like we're not
capable of doing these great things and
we downplay our role and we downplay how
important our mission is and we downplay
what we think we can do that's what
needs to
that's what needs to change you need to
feel like the work you do matters you
need to feel like the mission you're on
means something can have a big impact
and if you're approaching life in that
way everything in your business changes
I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I use to help and I think
it'll help you too setep number one is
have a Big Y and a little y so the Big Y
is your mission is your vision is what
you're trying to accomplish right it's
this big thing that you're trying to go
off and do and it should be inspiring it
should be bold it should be something
that you can't just do tomorrow right
it's got to be this big thing that's
all-encompassing that maybe will never
happen in your lifetime sometimes with
the Big Y feels a little too big
sometimes that Big Y feels like it's
never going to happen you can't do it
you don't have the skills the resources
the capabilities and so when that seed
of Doubt Creeps in is when I use the
little why the little y are the day-to-
day so if my goal if I want to solve
human potential right I want everybody
in the world to believe in themselves I
want to help a billion entrepreneurs
whatever I'm I'm pulling from if that
ever feels too big what I'll do is look
at the little y of well I help somebody
today or I helped somebody yesterday
I'll look at my YouTube comments I'll
look at my Instagram comments I I'll see
the stories that come in from the emails
and say Evan thank you so much for XYZ
every day I get lots of them and that
fuels me those are the little y's so I
may not be hitting my Big Y but I I know
that the work I do matters that's at the
core of what you need to feel that the
work that you do matters is having an
impact means something to people now you
might say well Evan you're fortunate now
you've got all these followers and
subscribers and it's easy to get love
and accolades and it is it's true I'm
I'm spoiled every day I get tons of
comments and it's almost all positive
but I did this when I was just getting
started I did this before I even had a
YouTube channel I used to have these
moments when I was speaking I did these
events in Toronto helping local
entrepreneurs and and I would go and do
my speech and and do workshop and help
people and I felt so amazing after
amazing like man yes this is so great
what I'm doing and then I would wake up
the next day and feel like I I don't
know what I do isn't important wake up
the next day and feel like I don't know
this there's no meaning in what I'm
doing I got nothing on my plate today
and so it have these spikes of purpose
and spikes of of momentum and spikes of
belief and then fall back down to
feeling like it doesn't mean anything I
think we have a daily reset and so I
think you need to remind yourself daily
that what you do is important so what I
did when I didn't have a big following
was I put together a PowerPoint file of
some of the comments that came out of my
workshop so when I did a workshop people
people would sometimes email me in or we
had these feedback forms and they'd
write something down about what they
liked or didn't like and the positive
ones about how I've I've impacted their
life I would put on this PowerPoint file
that I would look at every morning so I
put it to music that I liked and then
have these words pop up like yeah it's
just a reminder that that what I do
matters it means something and I think
you need it on a daily basis because no
matter how great you may feel today
tomorrow you're starting up from almost
Ground Zero again and you can slowly
shift Ground Zero over time what your
Baseline becomes from from one year to
the next might be different but on a
day-to- day you don't see it that much
and so you need to inject that into your
day every day and so sometimes the Big Y
is enough sometimes the big why is yeah
of course you're going to go off and
crush and go do these amazing things
sometimes it's not enough and you got to
remind yourself of the little wise that
hey I impacted somebody yesterday I
impacted somebody today so you feel like
the work you do matters makes a huge
difference setep number two is chart
your start so along the lines of Big Y
little Y what your morning r looks like
matters it makes a difference most
people wake up like an accident most
people wake up and fall into somebody
else's version of what their life should
be you pick up your phone and you start
dealing with emergencies and emails and
crisis and DMS and you don't control
your day successful people don't do that
successful people have a routine that
sets them up for Success that demands
Excellence everybody wakes up and and
and you're tired and you're just getting
started and you don't have full energy
nobody wakes up and like yeah oh my gosh
it's Wednesday I'm so excited like
that's not how it happens but but they
demand that of themselves right and so
the morning routine that you create for
yourself has to lead to you feeling that
way feeling bold feeling confident
feeling Unstoppable and so much more
important than what I do or what Eric
does as morning routine is thinking what
do you do what do you need to do what
makes you feel bold what makes you feel
confident what makes you feel alive and
then doing that every morning demanding
boldness from yourself every morning
charting your start so that every
morning you wake up and you do the thing
that helps you believe more in yourself
most people if they have a morning
routine you're just check in the boxes
like okay watch your video check write
in my journal check you know eat a
healthy breakfast check check check
check you're checking it off but if you
don't have the feeling behind it it
doesn't count you might have spent two
hours going through your ideal morning
routine and checked everything off but
you don't feel bold and Unstoppable fail
it didn't work sometimes it's just a
little bit more intention maybe watching
videos help you but if you're doing it
while you're checking your phone and
while you're eating breakfast and while
you're doing three other things you
don't get the feeling of the video right
or reading the book or anything else
you're distracted you're not focused you
don't have the intention of this has to
make me feel bold this has to be an
amazing day for myself right demanding
Excellence so chart your start whatever
the thing is that makes you feel bold
Unstoppable powerful has to be into your
daily routine every single day and
number three is have an environment of
Excellence the environment you're in
makes such a big difference you are a
product of your environment your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you exactly where you are so you
want to change it change your
environment you want to change your
situation in life change your
environment no that doesn't mean move to
Canada or move to the beaches or move to
some other country you may not be able
to afford that awesome figure it out
right now I can't meet Steve Jobs but I
can have him up on my wall start with
your office environment wherever office
is if it's a home office an natural
office a basement you know your mom's
couch what whatever it is wherever your
office is design the beauty of this
these may not mean much to you but it
means something to me and I walk in
every day and all these pictures have a
reason and a story for and so I put them
up once I had to decide once what do I
want to have on here that's going to
make me feel bold and then every day I
walk in and it just takes care of itself
I call them play bigger triggers these
are my play bigger triggers I'm standing
here working usually my monitors are
here so I'm looking at this and then I
got Steve Jobs kind of staring me down
right here right say let's go Evan come
on come on let's go let's go right I do
it once and then every day he's staring
me down and and then AP janini and my
parents and Howard Schultz and Kanye
West and this is my environment these
are my play bigger triggers you set it
up once and it inspires you daily right
next look at what's on your computer
background look at your screens what's
on your computer background what's on
your cell phone background should be
something that inspires you inspires you
to play bigger your play bigger trigger
so anywhere that you're hanging out
often your office your car if you drive
a lot your bedroom your screens all of
it make sure there's a play bigger
trigger to infuse boldness in you on a
consistent basis every single day rule
number five the last one before our very
special bonus clip
believe whether you believe you can or
you can't you're right right whether you
believe you can or you can't you're
right one of the biggest reasons why
entrepreneur don't win because you don't
believe in yourself enough it's why why
do I have this channel why is my one
word Bel look look at the back and Nina
sweater there it is right believe
believe that's it it's so important
there's so many you guys are geniuses
there's so many Geniuses massively
talented people out there with amazing
ideas that can change the world but you
don't go off and crush it because you
don't believe in yourself enough I think
the two biggest problems in the world
are one recognizing that you have
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
believing that you have something in you
that you're not meant to just wake up
and photocopy your life every day
working for somebody else just believing
that and two then believing in that
ability
believing that you have Michael Jordan
level Talent at something and then when
you found it believing in it enough to
chase it down every day to get better
cuz you need to beat on your craft
because it may be something that's
totally outside what is normal in your
family because it may be something way
outside what is normal for your culture
or your Society or Community but you
have to go off and do that crazy thing
and it's really hard to believe in
yourself enough to chase it down
especially when it's against what
everybody around you is saying and what
they believe and so great yes I need to
believe in myself amazing how do you do
it what's the process how do you gain
self-belief I'm going to give you two
strategies that will work extremely well
can work for anybody can work for you
because it's time that you step into
your greatness number one you need to
eliminate the negativity in your life
and replace it with belief so think
about what are the thoughts who are the
people what are the things around you
that keep you where you are that keep
these negative patterns in your head is
it your parents is it your friends is it
the TV shows you're watching the media
you're consuming like what is it that is
toxic that makes you feel small and as
much as possible you either cut it out
of your life or reduce the exposure if
it's your mom who's always on you and
said you can't go be an entrepreneur
maybe you just don't talk about your
career with your mom you put boundaries
up I don't want to talk about this
there's other things that we have in
common you focus on that stuff you lay
out the ground rules you make them
respect you and you don't talk about the
things that you know is going to lead to
conflict and for other people you may
need to just completely cut them out of
your life if it's your best friend from
growing up just because you are friends
in grade four doesn't mean you should
still be friends of adults a lot of our
friendships are out of convenience
you're with people just because it's
convenient to be with people but you've
grown apart and you have to recognize
that if somebody's toxic around you you
shouldn't be with them and if you are
it's micro does and so you need to cut
out a lot of the crap in your life
anything that's causing negativity or
self-doubt needs to be eliminated from
your life as much as possible great now
you have a vacuum now you've got this
hole not is that is this void in inside
you great what do you do you fill it up
with positivity you fill it up with
belief my channel is a pretty good
resource I got this channel I got the
other channels we got three videos plus
a day coming out across my channels that
if you want more belief in your life
here's a great resource for you but
forget about me it's not about me it's
about you what makes you feel belief if
it's watching videos great if it's
listening to a podcast reading a book
doing an active service meditating
prayer whatever the thing is that helps
you feel belief do that every single day
fill yourself up with it I inject myself
with so much vitamin C belief I see
belief as this injection I put into
myself every day I have so much of it in
me that if somebody sneezes their
toxicity on me I'm not going to get sick
because I've done the work because I'm
surrounded with so much belief that's
what you need for your life as well so
you're cutting out the negative people
you're cutting out the negative
resources and you're replacing with
positivity so that when somebody does
sneeze they're toxic on you you're not
going to get sick cuz you've taken so
much belief vitamin see so that's the
first step eliminate those people
replace it with positivity and belief
whatever that thing is for you step
number two is you got to start acting
you got to start doing things that make
you believe in yourself you got to take
a challenge that you didn't think you
could do and start doing it for some
people it's as simple as not hitting the
snooze button in the morning for some of
you hitting the snooze button is the
hardest thing in the world great make
that your goal for the next month you're
going to wake up every day when you say
you're going to wake up you're going to
set your alarm and you're just going to
get up when it goes off and you're going
to celebrate and you're going to start
building self-belief that you're the
kind of person this is what you need to
set you're the kind of person who
follows through you set goals and you
follow through you set goals and you
follow through the problem is you have
an identity where you don't follow
through you don't believe yourself you
say you're going to do something but
then you know you're not going to do it
you say you're going to go off and do
this big thing but you know you're not
going to do it CU you don't do the
little things cuz you can't even wake up
on time cuz you let yourself down on
your goals and so you need to make sure
that every time you set a goal you
follow through you do it you start
training yourself I'm the kind of person
who sets goals and who follows through
and so it starts with what happens in
the morning right you wake up when you
see you're going to get up what happens
next what's the next piece of your
morning routine right and then you do
that every single day you follow through
and so you have to be very very very
very very very very careful about the
goals that you say you're going to do
because when you say you're going to do
something you have to follow through
when I started this whole 90-day tour
our first St was Boston I got in at 2:00
in the morning at the time I had a goal
of doing 30 minutes of cardio every day
while Nina Danny everybody else slept I
did my 30 minutes of cardio it was the
worst cardio of all time I burned zero
calories on it I should have been
sleeping but I Pat myself on the back
because when it's hard and you do it
that's when you build the belief when
it's easy and you do it nobody cares you
don't care about it cuz it was easy but
when it's hard and you do it when it's
hard to wake up at 5: in the morning
when you say you're going to because you
had a rough night and you do it that's
when you build self-belief now if you're
doing that every day you're only
sleeping 4 hours not every day your life
is broken you got to fix it but on a
oneof you have to get up you have to do
it you have to set goals and you have to
follow through that's this two-step
process whether you believe you can or
you can't you're right how do you build
belief one eliminate the negativity
replace it with positivity two take on
challenges set goals for yourself and
then actually follow through in them if
you don't believe in yourself you're
never going to do great things you're
always going to have one foot on the gas
and one foot on the break at the same
time you know you're capable of more you
know you're capable of great things you
know you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something
but because you don't believe in
yourself you don't chase it down and so
you live in this cycle of negativity of
knowing that you're capable of more and
frustration and I want to unlock that I
mean that's the whole point of all of my
content and my channels I want to unlock
that and those two steps if that's you
right now will dramatically change your
life you will be if you just did those
two things every day for the next year
you will be a dramatically different
person holy cow one year from today
looking back you will be a dramatic a
different person the things you will
have accomplished will surprise you and
I'm so pumped to cheer you
on that negative voice inside your head
that's telling you that you suck and you
can't do it that's not your voice that's
not actually your voice that's not you
telling yourself that you suck that
voice was planted there that voice was
put there by somebody else in your life
and probably early on growing up telling
you that you can't do something you were
not born you didn't come out of the womb
and say I suck I can't do anything no
you're playing you're experimenting
you're finding Joy you're laughing
you're you're doing it and then along
the way people tell you that you can't
do it that you should stop that you
should quit that that it's not going to
work out that you can't do it and we've
been so conditioned around that that we
take it on and we think it's our
voice when you come up with an idea
right just Workshop this you come up
with an idea like I'm going to I'm going
to go I'm going to write a book I'm
going to start a YouTube channel I'm
going to launch this business I'm going
to whatever you come with your your
bucket list your your dream life your
vision board you come with a list of
ideas things that you think that you
want to do things that you feel
confident that you'd love to create for
yourself right okay what happens the
next day the next day it's not even
telling our friends you know I think we
we blame our friends and say well we
tell our friends and they're going to be
negative and and they they they crap on
our idea and so we don't do it well
before that happens we crap on our own
ideas right you look at that list and
next day and say I can't do that who who
who was I yesterday this crazy person
that I used to be yesterday who thought
I could do that it's ourselves telling
ourselves that we suck but the problem
is we've taken on that voice and we
think that it's us that's not your voice
that is not your voice telling you that
you suck that is somebody else's voice
that was planted in your head that has
been conditioned to be there that we're
so used to being there that we have
taken on as our voice it has become your
identity but it was not your voice it
was put there it was a seed that was
planted that has been grown over time
and you need to rip that weed out that
is not your voice you do not think that
you
suck it's other people with low
expectations who hate their own lives
who at some point went and tried
something that did not work out for
their life and now nobody around them
can have success because it makes them
look and feel bad and so they spend
their time ripping other people down and
apart that's who planted that weed in
your head that might hit pretty hard I
hope it does cuz when that H when if you
can
actually digest that what ends up happen
is you think oh who whose voice is that
who whose voice is in my head and that's
great awareness to know that it's not
your voice and then to identify whose
voice it is who told you these things
who made you feel this way growing up
and if you think about who that person
is if you can actually picture somebody
oh that was Uncle Joe or oh that was my
grade three teacher oh or that was my
you know the bully at school whoever
that person was now think about okay
it's that person's voice not you that's
already incredibly liberating but but
then too do you want to live that
person's life like think about that
person probably they're not living a
great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life if you don't
want their life then you definitely
don't want their voice in your head
anymore hopefully that creates an aha
moment for you that starts to actually
shift things because we've been so
conditioned to listen to that voice that
we don't recognize that we actually have
a choice to rip it out and start to
listen to our own voice we have a big
mission to change the world right I'm
and it's like okay our mediate goal I
need and maybe we hit that in a couple
months have to it doesn't have to take
the December to that's you're going to
leave but we can if you have 10 clients
who are still we're happy too right very
much so but the immedate goal is not
it's not some crazy thing that you're
coming in to say I need to have right a
thousand clients paying me right yeah so
it's five clients five clients between
now and de right perfect at a minimum so
then it's who are the best people who
can afford you to pay
$2,000 a month if you connect better
with women we fine it's women it's not
that you only have to do one but it's
it's helpful to yeah narrow in on like
the right influences to take you to the
path right
so is it women in careers so I honestly
mostly been I haven't coached any woman
been coaching men okay um and it's been
the people who I have been coaching are
people that are in the um like in the
fitness space so it's more about
figuring who are the people who have
budget who can hire you or you get paid
to come in to an organization and help
them with their team yeah exactly
honestly like as I think more about this
it's like how can I create the Maximum
Impact right not yet
okay no no this is where we get start
yeah exactly this is the Trap Maximum
Impact doesn't make you money in the
next three years well that's true and we
need we have a drop dead date December
231 yes yes for sure you're right and
right so but that's not the question
right now Maximum Impact we just at
impact right Maximum Impact on like
individuals but not world oh yes I
impact and we need to be paid to do it
so we can continue to build in scale
okay I think people who are going to
entrepreneurs is a really hard Market
because they just don't have yeah budget
right and especially if they quit their
job and then they go to start their
business then they have no more money to
pay you yeah so the coaching will
probably end absolutely so it's finding
people who are it could be if you're
making a quarter million plus a year and
you want to start a business yeah you
know I'm I'm I'm going to help you and I
would get the 25k up
front
once they start the business it's going
to be really hard to yeah right and I
collect after every session okay yeah up
front yeah like all of that it could be
potentially negotiable right could I do
quarterly installments could I do just 6
months you don't have to say no to it
but you can say like here's here's
here's what we did I think comparison to
other people is fantastic I think most
people just do it wrong I think most
people just do it wrong you look at
somebody else you see their life you see
what they're doing you see their
business you see their success you see
how old they are is one of the common
questions people ask well how old are
you well typically it's because they
want to they want to judge their own
progress against
yours the comparison can be great but
you have to use it as a kick forward
instead of a kick down most people will
kick themselves down they realize that
you haven't you realize you haven't done
much you realize that you're not where
you want to be you realize all these
other people have done it with maybe
less resources than you at an earlier
age than you and you feel like it's over
and you can't do it that's a kick down
it's a comparison it's a kick down and
that's what most people do and that's
why there's so much advice out there
from people saying don't compare
yourself to others because when we do it
we typically kick ourselves down that's
the wrong way to do it the comparison to
other people comes from knowing what's
possible and being inspired to want to
go off and do it you know I just came
back from a trip with um my beach gang
and it's bigname people it's Brendon
bashard and Mel Robbins and uh Lewis
house and J shett and you know all these
all these big people who've done big
things and we sit around the
table and we share and we help and it's
our own Mastermind it's not a paid thing
it's where they go and and and we all
share and as they're talking as they're
sharing what they're up to and what
they're working
towards I'm thinking that's what's
possible that's what I could do if I
wanted to that's what that's how they're
doing their marketing okay if I could do
this and maybe they're 3 years ahead of
me but by learning their strategies I
can get there in 6
months the comparison pushes you forward
runners run faster when there's somebody
next to them businesses innovate faster
when there's
competition comparing yourself to who
you were yesterday is not enough of a
push forward that's the problem
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday is is a great it's great for
self-love but it's not enough of a
push so I'd encourage you to start
thinking about an audit for yourself
right
now if you're really low if there's no
self-love if you don't feel like
anything is possible that's where you
look back and you look at the progress
that's when you look back and say where
was I 5 years ago where was I 10 years
ago look at how how much you've grown
and learned and improved and how much in
a better situation you are compared to
where you used to be even if not
financially just mindset just mentally
just the kind of person you are how you
treat people you've probably grown if
you're watching this channel it means
you're into personal growth
self-development so whether it's from my
videos or somebody else's content you've
been learning and growing over the past
5 years you've grown a lot you're not
the same person you used to be you're a
lot more proud of yourself than who you
used to be and whenever you're feeling
low on yourself that that's when you
look back and track the progress that's
when you look back and see who you used
to be and how much you've grown and
improved and gotten better and that can
start to fill you up
again but when you're ready for
growth when you're ready for ambition
when you're ready for the next level I
think the comparison is fantastic I
think to know that something is possible
it's the whole Roger banister 4minute
mile nobody thought it was possible then
Roger banister did it and now
everybody's doing it not everybody but a
lot of people did it why because they
were comparing themselves to him because
they know now that it's
possible and so when you see somebody
else do it when you see somebody else
making amazing things you don't have to
default to say I suck because they're
doing it and I'm not that's a kick down
you can
choose to use it as inspiration to say
that's what's possible and if she can do
it if he can do it then so can I and use
that as the push to get you to the next
level at our beach
gang last year I got challenged a couple
times I got challenged by Brendan I got
challenged by Russell Brunson I got
challenged by a whole bunch of people
and and I got challenged without people
even talking to me sometimes just by
them sharing their
story I look at that and say I want to
do
that not in the way that I suck and I
can't do it but no in a year I want to
be there in two years I want to be there
in 5 years I want to be there I want to
be there I want to be there I look at
young Les Brown I think he's the
greatest speaker of all time I don't
look at him and
say he's so much better than me he's got
this natural gift I suck I'm never going
to do it I look at him and I say I want
to be that good that's what's possible
it's an inspiration to move forward so
how do you make it tactical there's a
couple things that I think would be
helpful for you one look at some people
who you respect inside your industry or
outside it's just something that you
respect about them maybe it's me maybe
it's Jordan Peterson maybe it's Oprah
who who are the people that you look up
to and respect what are the things so
two what are the things about them then
that you want to get better at if you
respect somebody's because they're
they're ahead of you at something that
you want to be good at maybe it's in
their business maybe it's in their
speaking maybe it's in their
relationships they've done something or
they're living a way that is ahead of
you
so what is that thing too what is that
thing what is the thing that they have
that you are aspiring to get better
at there's no one person who is the
ideal Mentor you don't want to be me you
don't want to be Jordan Peterson you
don't want to be
Oprah they have parts of that I have
parts of my life that you don't want the
whole point is to take different pieces
from different people to make the best
you you want to I for me I want to be a
vision like Steve Jobs that's why he's
on my wall and I want to be a father
like my father was that's why he's on my
wall I don't want to be a father like
Steve Jobs was and I don't want to be a
Visionary like my
dad because they're not so you're taking
different people and different things
from them to help you become the best
you so one is you're making a list of
all the people that you look up to that
you respect that there's something about
them that you you gravitate towards two
you find that specific thing I want to I
want to have courage like this person I
want to have love like this person I
want to be a husband or or a wife like
this person right I want to be a mother
or father like this person that they're
the ideal to to shoot towards that
improve you to make you want to strive
to get better and then three you dive
into their story you dive into their
content you dive into their videos their
books their podcast their biographies
you dive into them on a consistent basis
watching One video is not enough it's a
consistent basis to help you start
to think like that somebody asked me
yesterday why do you read so many books
at a time I read uh seven to 10 books at
a time I never really thought about why
I do it it just seemed to work for me
but as I dissect it I love micro doing
on books I love micro doing on content
cuz think of what happens when you read
a book so one of the books I'm reading
right now is jett's Think Like a monk so
when you're reading jett's book it it
forces you to start thinking like a monk
it forces you to have more presence and
more gratitude and more mindfulness and
if you're going to read some hardcore
the other book another book I'm read is
75 hard from Andy frisella which is
inyour face hardcore punching you in the
stomach you know yelling at you let's
go two two totally different Vibes I
like both I don't want to be J shett I
don't want to be Andy
frisella but I like the mindfulness and
present of of Jett and I like the
aggressiveness and push of Anie forella
and in in that combination is Evan
carmichel so why I read seven to 10
books at a time is because the micro
doing of the books when you're reading a
book if I only read J shed's book I
become very mindful very grateful very
present and then I put the book down and
I pick up a different book and then what
you start to do is
lose the train of thought you lose the
thing that you learned from Jay unless
you're picking up another J ched book
but he's only got one out right
now so instead instead of going hardcore
and just reading one book I like having
J shett once a week I like having Andy
faella once a week I like in the videos
that I make to have different people we
have Jordan Peterson once a month and
Elon Musk once a month and Oprah once a
month because diving deep on one person
can be great but what happens on the
ongoing
I'm much more concerned about the
ongoing than I am about the what's
happening intense at the
moment because the ongoing is how you
win if you want to have success in
anything going going to the gym and
working out for 4 hours is not going to
do much for you but if you go to the gym
every day for half an hour you start to
see
results so all of that a bunch of stores
in there but the main concept is I think
comparison is fantastic you just have to
use it smartly when you look at somebody
else understand that you don't want
their entire life you don't want their
entire life but there's something about
them that they're better than you at and
use that as inspiration for you to get
better instead of you telling yourself
that you suck and you can't do it
comparison will push you forward
comparison will help you get the life
that you want as long as you're kicking
yourself forward not down is it get
really clear on what the Habit is that
you want to develop don't pick 20
different habits that you would want to
do all at once this is where we we
struggle because we take on way too much
like okay that's it I'm done I'm rolling
up my sleeves it's time to change my
life I've had it I've had enough I'm
going to change everything I'm going to
work out and I'm going to I'm going to
eat well and I'm going to make content
I'm going to grow my business I'm going
to find a girlfriend I'm going to like
whatever the thing is you come with 20
different habits that you're going to do
and guess what you do it tomorrow maybe
and then and then it becomes too
overwhelming too much too much change
all at once your life just takes over
and you end up back down in the hole
where you started has that happened if
you tried to take on too much at once
what is the single most important habit
that you need to start to build that if
you look back in a year you could say
I'm so happy that I built this one habit
because it's helping you accomplish your
goals what is the most important habit
it could be waking up at a certain time
it could be taking care of your your
mind it could be taking of your body it
could be putting in a certain amount of
work on your business it could be
writing your book it could be making a
100 videos like what is the one habit
that you want to start to build that if
that one thing happened your entire life
starts to change it's the Cornerstone
habit that you start doing that because
I guarantee you listen if you start
waking up at a certain time or you start
working out you can pick any of them you
start doing one of those things that
you're proud of yourself for doing it
other things start to change in your
life around you because when you feel
really proud of yourself when you feel
good about
yourself other things start to improve
too focus on who you are serving instead
of who you're not that one sentence is
at the core of how I've been able to
stay so consistent to keep making
content to not give up to not get too
discouraged and to get back up every
single time and keep going because I
focus on who I am sir instead of who I'm
not I just recently spoke at Bren Bard's
influencer Summit and I shared my
graphic of how I've grown over the years
on my channel every time I show that
graph they always asked me how did you
keep going in in the first 5 years when
you had no subscribers when you had no
comments how did you keep going and how
did you make so many videos how did you
not burn out how have you made 12,000
videos over 12 years how how do you keep
doing it and I don't think I'm super
human I don't think I'm I'm extra
special uh I think I had actually more
problems than most I'm I'm shy I'm
introverted I was afraid of the camera I
felt like only egotistical people put
themselves on camera and told their
story um I had lots of limiting beliefs
and struggles in getting my channel and
just belief in myself to put anything
out there I hated my first 350 videos I
couldn't watch anything back totally
embarrassed by everything I made uh and
it was 750 videos before I inspired
myself before I finally liked one of my
own videos like you know what I'm
starting to get decent at this that was
a good video 750 videos in before I did
that so how how how do you keep going
how does that make any sense because I
always focus on who I was serving
instead of who I
wasn't most of us just focus on who
we're not serving think about your
growth think about if you you made any
kind of
content you know at the beginning you
you get nothing right there's no
reaction there's no comments and then
maybe you get one comment and then maybe
you get five comments or maybe you get
10 likes or maybe you get however many
views on your videos right you get 100
views on your video now that's kind of
the standard now if you get 20 views
again on a video oo that that that
doesn't feel so good right or if you get
a th000 views on a video or 10,000 views
on a or 100,000 views on a video I
remember the first time I got 100,000
views on a video it's like wow I've made
it and then it's easier to feel like oh
the next video got 10% of that and you
feel like oh I I suck it's not working
right instead of focusing on that
because that's a losing
game focus on who you are helping and
assume that it is serving people if you
want a guaranteed way to move into
action apply the 595 rule spend 5% of
your time planning and 95% of of your
time doing 5% planning 95% doing most
people are afraid to apply the 595 rule
because you're afraid that you'll take
the wrong action that you'll make a
mistake that it won't be perfect but
here's what's going to happen while you
are sitting there planning your perfect
next move someone with less Talent with
less skills than you will win with a
half-baked idea because they applied the
595 Rule and just got started
entrepreneurs generally don't have a lot
of P and that's actually a good thing we
want things now we want to hustle hard
we want to see the results of our labor
paying off we want to see you know
change happening we have a big Vision we
know it can work and we want it to
happen right now and that's that's
that's amazing and I want you to hold on
to it and at the same time I want you to
have incredible patience because what
ends up happening is entrepreneurs often
quit too soon you had the right idea you
had the right Vision you even had the
right execution in setting it up but you
just quit you thought it was going to
happen in 3 months where it's actually
going to happen in 3 years for what
you're doing every single day you need
to be applying yourself and close off
every other opportunity for 4 years and
then you'll be successful 4 years ago on
my YouTube channel I had 7,000 is
subscribers four years ago how did I get
here with 1.2 million by making videos
every single day every single day we
haven't missed a day in 4 years and in
the past two or 3 years has been three
times a day or at least two times a day
just grinding it out and in those little
micro moments in those micro videos it's
super impatience right it's like this
video has to deliver this video now has
to deliver this next one this one right
here has to deliver there's a lot of
impatience to make things happen and
it's knowing that this is going to take
me years to get to where I want to go
and so many of you watching could have
had more Talent than I did my first
videos were not very good I was not
natural natural in front of the camera
it took a lot of effort a lot of
patience a lot of doing a video over and
over and over and over and over and over
again entire day making one video just
being in front of the camera and it
still sucked a lot of you were starting
from a place that's way better than me I
had zero editing skills zero knowledge
about lighting and technique and all of
that stuff I sucked I had
nothing but I did it for 4 years and
here we are and I'm going to do it again
for those of you who are following my
journey who say well now I'm already big
I have 1.2 million subscribers you know
you're not a small YouTuber anymore come
follow me on Instagram I've got 8,000
followers now 8,000 something I started
taking it seriously about a month ago
had 6,000 followers we've grown I'm
going to do the same thing I'm going to
put in work on Instagram do three posts
every single day for 4 years and and I'm
going to learn the algorithm and learn
the ins and outs and fix my design and
every day there's new changes that are
coming out that I wasn't doing the day
before cuz I've learned cuz I sucked and
I still suck and and I'm learning to get
better and for those of you who are
already way ahead of me for those of you
who have way more talent and design and
just natural skill at this stuff we may
already have 50,000 followers or 100,000
followers on Instagram I'm coming and
it's not a race that like that I'm
better than you and that I'm going to
I'm going to get there and you won't
it's just the work like I will have the
patience to do three posts a day for 4
years cuz I know it's going to pay off
my Horizon is today like the post that I
make today has to rock I have to be
proud of it I want to show Hayden I want
to show my grandkids about the post that
I'm making right now today I want my
grandkids to see this single individual
video right now that I am posting that's
the energy and passion and fire and fuel
that I try to bring to every single
piece of content that I make I want it
to matter I want it to mean something to
myself and to Future Generations that's
that's my intention I can't always bring
that out I don't always execute but
that's the intention every single time
in creating anything that I do has to
mean something has to matter and then
I'm going to do that for 4 years three
times a day and that's how I'll win and
that's how you can win I'm trying to
show this to you not to impress you but
to impress upon you that you probably
already have more skills than I do and
that you can do this too you're just
giving up too soon I want to tell you
that your mission is important I want to
tell you that your idea is brilliant
that you are a genius that you can make
this happen that you don't need to sit
on your couch and watch somebody else
make millions of dollars off of your
idea you're just not putting in enough
consistent work you start and you stop
and you start and you stop and you start
and you stop and it's not consistent
where if you just did the thing every
day for four years you will win and so
that's why it's so it's so important
that you love the process and not just
the result that you were doing this
because you love the actual work not
just hitting the million subscribers or
the million revenue or whatever the
thing is you're chasing whatever the
goal the goals are great to give some
extra motivation but the drive comes
from the work the meaning the actual
process I like making videos I like now
making Instagram posts right you have to
find a thing that you love to do and
then shut off the part of you that is so
impatient that you need immediate
results shut off the judgments from your
friends friends and your family who say
what are you doing you've been doing
this for 6 months and it hasn't worked
out yet yeah I know cuz I'm on a four
five year plan I'm going to keep doing
the same thing I'm going to keep getting
better I'm going to keep improving I'm
going to keep posting I'm going to keep
creating I'm going to keep pushing for
four or five years and then I will win
and all of the the success comes at the
last part all of the learning and the
momentum and the traction starts now but
it feels so small It Feels So intangible
it feels so little but if you keep doing
it
you will see massive growth in year
three in year four in year five and
it'll be so Unstoppable because it'll be
like this huge Avalanche that just keeps
building and building and building upon
all the work that you put in and so it's
great to have the impatience your
impatience should be on a daily basis
the impatience should be driving you
consistently forward to make whatever
you do today make it awesome and you
need to have insane patience to know
that this is not going to happen in 3
months or 6 months or a year to have a
longer Horizon to think I will do this
for four or 5 years and then I will win
if you take that approach I guarantee
you that you will win and I'm so
fighting for you to win I so badly want
to see you win I so know that you can
win and I'm so pumped I'm so pumped I'm
so pumped for 4 years from now to see a
handful of you say I listened to that
message I applied it and I won so pumped
for 4 years from now please please you
please you be be that person be
consistent be patient your mission is
important you are a genius your ideas
will work out be
consistent because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
and if you want to watch Evan's top 10
rules for Success check out the video
next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
and I think for the first 20 or so years
I really lived through that lens of
future regret like whenever I didn't
know how it would turn out and was
afraid of doing something I would use
that model of